#HOLOYOLO and #MaterialYOLO have
both been used to praise and
ridicule Android design.
So, what's the deal with them?
Much like the New York City skyline,
design in Android didn't come out fully
formed, but slowly built over time.
In the beginning, there were years of
desolation where Android users had to
wait a long time for first party apps.
And when they finally did come,
in many cases,
they were exact ports
of the iOS versions.
This all changed with the release
of Android 3.0 Honeycomb and
its HOLO theme.
The HOLO theme and
its refinements continued to flourish
in Ice Cream Sandwich,
Jelly Bean, and Kit Kat.
HOLOYOLO became a rallying call from
the users that expected the apps
they use to look like Android.
Sometimes, before the next
version was out of beta.
No longer could you say
that Android users and
developers don't care about design.
With the release of
Android 5.0 Lollipop,
#HOLOYOLO gave way to #MaterialYOLO.
We learned in this course we really
shouldn't use the material theme if we
want to make our apps
backward compatible.
If anything,
we should say #AppCompatYOLO.
You know?